It's not as bad as him.
I've passed your car,
you only got that strap,
you know,
you're moving around and banging around in there and in the race car you were in
there pretty tight.
Yeah.
Do you feel weird when you're in a passenger car too is for the lack of support,
lack of support and safety?
You know,
I,
I do because compared to way the way our cup cars are now or the race cars are
now,
man were cocooned in their,
the seat and everything.
The headrest,
you got six,
seven point harness.
I mean in the street car you really just got the strap.
I mean it's um,
uh,
certainly,
you know,
and more,
I'm much more cautious as I get older on the highway and,
and people like,
hey man,
how do you do that?
How do you drive on how you drive a race car and then go 45,
55 on the road?
And it's really easy actually,
you know,
just kinda chill out all your fast driving out of the way.
When I was younger I was getting speeding tickets all the time.
But when as I got older I just didn't care to be in a hurry anymore.
Yeah,
I would figure the way you drive for a living,
you just get it out of your system.
Yeah,
plenty of.
I had plenty and plenty of high speed action and high jinks on the race track.
I don't,
I calmed down the road.
What kind of car do you drive in real life?
Well,
it's funny,
I um,
uh,
just bought a brand new Silverado.
I hadn't bought a truck and a long time.
I had,
I still have my old Silverado about what it's about Oh four oh six.
But there's new one.
Uh,
I like a lot of new ones are bad.
I didn't like the old ones that much.
They just look kind of basic.
The new ones are really sweet looking,
the character lines and the body lines.
It's just a good looking truck.
So I bought that.
Um,
but my,
what I was driving before that I got a 48 a pickup truck and uh,
it's all rough as hell on the outside and um,
original faded all messy and ugly looking,
but it's got a Vortec motor and good drive train in it drives good but it's easy
to work on and I just love fooling with it.
I took the original Binks bench seat out and put these old bucket seats in from
an 80 a Chevy blazer and a,
so I made it comfortable and just the way I wanted it.
So I drive,
I drove that a lot this summer until I got this new truck and I got a 76 Chevy
Laguna that I love to drive.
Yeah.
That thing just kind of floats,
floats down the road,
man.
It's a dark midnight blue tinted windows and just a really cool,
because I love the 70s in the style of the cars in the 70s even though kind of
the bigger ones,
like in the late seventies,
like the four 42 Oldsmobile cutlass,
those big,
big,
big cars.
There's something about those guys that I really did cause that your car,
that's my car right there.
Yeah.
I love that thing man.
I had a 1973 Chevelle.
Yeah.
That reminds me of that kind of body style.
That's it.
I got it for 42.
That's sort of the sister that also bill for 42 that's red and um,
kind of the same.
Tended wouldn't same.
I did the same wheels,
same tire,
same tent,
same.
I put a spoiler like a NASCAR style spoiler on the back of the front and kind of
look because those cars were big in Nascar.
Uh,
so those,
those cars don't get as much love as the 16th muscle cars.
Well,
we'll get there.
I think as we get older.
That what cool gets older.
Reemay yeah.
Like I mean nothing.
I mean this camera,
the 67 Camaro,
those cards if 50.
Yeah.
I got a 67.
I thought I had a 69,
but uh,
like the 55 shit,
all those things will always hold their rightful place in history.
But these cars,
like that car right there or that wasn't very cool.
10 15,
20 years ago.
No,
but as we get older,
that car becomes cool,
you know,
and,
and you know,
one day we'll be driving around in like a 85 pickup trucks going,
man,
this thing,
so,
so awesome.
So yeah.
Thanks.
So I may know about that.
I just think that the car might just be cool cause you own it.
I don't know.
I think that it's got these old character lines,
man.
And I really like,
it does have old care.
You know what's interesting?
I was,
I was just talking to a friend of mine about this when in 1970 uh,
my mom bought a barracuda.
Yeah.
And when I was in high school in 1981 I was a freshman in high school and she
had this Barracuda and it was like a classic car and there was like a classic
muscle car.
Right.
But like that's the only 11 years old.
Yeah.
Like if you had a car today from 2007 well,
there,
yeah.
You wouldn't be a car class car.
Yeah.
You're right.
It's weird.
It is weird.
Like a 1969 when I was in high school in 1969 which is only an 11 year old car
was amazing.
Like whoa.
People would stop and stare at it.
Dude.
Look at that 69 Camaro.
I got an 88 s 10 that was the first pickup truck I owned or had,
that was like what the car I got when I was 16 years old and I got one and
restored it and a,
which was a terrible investment.
But um,
it makes sense for me because it,
you know,
because it was my first truck and I didn't think anybody would give a shit about
it.
Right.
Cause it's an Stn,
it's like the bottom of the barrel and pickup trucks for Chevrolet in 1988 and,
and,
but I drive that thing around and people were like,
wow,
that's the cleanest as 10 I've seen in,
you know,
1520 years.
That's it right there.
Oh,
that's a nice car.
And so,
I mean that's what's something about seeing one of those,
it's in great shape.
Yeah,
I like that it made it through.
there's not many of them left.
I mean for,
for good reason.
But what was your first car?
My first car was a 73 Chevelle,
a 70 Chevelle Chevelles good car man.
Oh I love,
she's so would you buy a civil,
would you get a 73 and restore it to what would get a 76 my favorite.
You're 69 and 70 are my favorite years.
I go back and forth between 69 70 with Chevelles.
Both amazing years.
Yeah.
I liked those cars.
They're,
they're uh,
they're a big muscle car.
Yards.
A big ride.
It's bigger than the Camaro.
Yeah.
I have a 1969 Nova.
Really?
Yeah.
I would just like a smaller,
yeah,
like that right there.
Ooh Daddy looking car.
That is as classic and American muscle cars you get.
It's a 1970 with silver with black stripes.
Camo and I used to race Novas my dad raced a Nova.
Yeah.
No,
I liked novas cause the light is a light car and cause you know,
you put a big engine in it and new suspension and you know,
I have a,
a Nova,
a wagon that I just bought a 66.
Oh Wow.
That's my next project,
um,
about it from a buddy for five grand and um,
it's in,
it's,
it's pretty bad shape,
but I'm going to,
that's my next project.
Soon as I get some time I had this little girl,
um,
Allah and she's six months.
Um,
so it's kind of made it tough to do any kind of project with Greg.
Thanks.
It's awesome.
But it does,
uh,
it does eat up a lot.
Everything is on the side right now and it will be
forever
until they move out.
And then it's still a little bit on the side cause you got a call and check on
them.
Yeah.
It's awesome though.
It is this amazing.
I couldn't,
it's like getting married and having a kid and all that stuff is not nothing
like I thought it'd be.